[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he's mike florio pro football talk live
co-host we figured we'd ask mike to
unwrap some things that we had yesterday
and last night let me start with aaron
rodgers last night with kenny mayne
big takeaway was well you know i think
kenny mayne did a great job of
continuing in a very
subtle and understated way to get aaron
rodgers
to say something i thought he wasn't
going to say anything and then
eventually
he launches into this monologue about
it's all about the people
it's all about the people dan didn't you
know that professional
football is all about the people it's
not about winning games or
making money or quickly and immediately
throwing overboard one player and
bringing in another one whenever it's in
the best interest of the team it's
actually about
the people at least that's the way it's
always been in green bay it's
always about the people i i don't know
what world aaron rodgers is currently
living in
but it's never been about the people
they have say it's about the people
they'll say football is family because
it's good for business to say football
is family but
he's adopted this unrealistic idealistic
view
of life in green bay and look
i don't think he believes it i think
this is just his way of getting the fans
on his side
in his ongoing battle with management of
the team which
all of a sudden has forgotten that it's
all about the people
yeah i wonder what his goal was last
night mike
i think plain and simple dan whatever
he's got planned for the 2021
season whether it's holding out whether
it's showing up and being
a constant irritant for the front office
whatever it is
he does not want to be reviled the way
brett favre was and remember they wanted
brett favre
out i firmly believe they went to brett
favre february 2008 knowing full well
what his answer would be
and said to him we need to know right
now what you're gonna do are you in or
are you out february he's out
july he's in too late brett sorry we've
drafted seven quarterbacks
we've got aaron rodgers you're gone and
even then
even then when brett favre did we had
duke to continue his career the fans
hated him because he ended up in
minnesota
i think rogers doesn't want to be the
subject of that ire even though it'll be
fixed in four or five years and they'll
welcome him back he doesn't want to go
through that
so he's trying to get the fans on his
side
and against the front office i really
think that's why he said what he said
because
we know that that you know football is a
cold hard ruthless business it's not
about the people it's about the people
as long as the people can help you the
moment they can it's about other people
and that's the way it goes it's a
constant revolving door
why not just come out and say he could
say all of these things
the fans the tradition everything
and then say but you know it's about
trust and
i you know the front office doesn't have
trust in me and how that went down
and it's best that i move on they they
drafted jordan love
and i love him and i i hope he gets a
chance he's a good kid
but it feels like you know what they bet
against me they didn't think i was going
to be good
and i'm the mvp and that's okay i hate
leaving
and but you know what they can move on
and all move on and and
i hope to see you down the road well
first of all you can't have a beautiful
mystery if you don't contribute to the
beautiful mystery
by saying vague and ambiguous things but
you touched on something there dan
at one point rogers said that he threw a
wrench in their plans by winning the mvp
i think he believes that they were going
to transition from him to jordan love
after one season yes
that rogers was on the way down they saw
maybe some signs of slippage in 2019
even though they went 13-3
and look you don't trade up to get
jordan love in round one unless you got
a plan for the guy
you're not saying what the hell well you
know we got a pretty good team we don't
need to make it any better
to get to the next level let's just go
ahead and waste a couple of draft picks
on a first round
prospect at quarterback and we'll see if
he turns into anything they had a plan
and he believes they delayed their plan
and now he's taking the initiative
because they want him on a year-to-year
arrangement they like having the ability
after each season to say
do we keep him or do we go with jordan
love and i think fundamentally what
rogers wants
or wanted i don't know what he wants now
but at some point he wanted
a commitment that would tie the team to
him
for multiple years because that's the
thing dan he's got the right to be
pissed off
he's never wavered in his commitment to
the team he's
always said packers for life play till
i'm
40 or beyond he's never done the brett
favre will i or won't i
and and and i think he thought that made
him immune
to this type of treatment and he's still
dealing with it
14 months later mike florio pro football
talk live co-host
but then i started to look at trade
scenarios why go to denver
if denver has to give up what a couple
of first-round picks
maybe a player a starter on defense
so you're gonna go there and live
happily ever after
this isn't peyton manning going to the
broncos
well the broncos have a pretty good team
if they would have a pretty good
quarterback to go along with it and
yeah if you start giving up future first
round picks that
undermines your ability to get better
moving forward
but there is going to be a price to be
paid if they trade him and
you know i made the argument last week
dan that this is the best time for the
packers to trade him
i don't think they ever get more for him
than they get
coming off of an mvp season i don't
think they want to trade him
i don't think they want him playing for
somebody else i really don't
i think mark murphy the ceo of the team
his safest
path is to take the position with aaron
rodgers play for us
play for no one and if you don't want to
play for anyone fine we'll take the 30
million back
that we already paid you that you owe us
and we'll we'll
buy other players with that but we'll
never have to worry about what you do
with another team we never have to worry
about after two or three years with
denver you end up with the vikings or
the lions or the bears
and then we got to deal with you twice
per year we're never gonna look stupid
we're never gonna look bad
if you just go home and never play again
i really think
they'd prefer number one he stays for
another year
number two he never plays for anyone and
then number three
worst case scenario they trade him to
another team what do you think happens
well i i go back and forth on this the
next big decision point is the mandatory
mini camp he gave up 500 000
by skipping the off-season program and i
know he's got
a crapload of money but you always take
another 500 thousand dollars if you can
get it
for showing up and throwing a football
around for a couple of weeks that's good
money
to turn your nose up out even if you
just give it to charity it's 500 grand
that he's not going to see
will he show up for mandatory mini camp
next month
i think there's a chance he won't and
just just as a way to test the water
see what the reaction is if he doesn't
show and then the question is is he
going to be there
for training camp but you know danny was
talking about being down 15 pounds
at some point you got to get the armor
back on your body or you're not going to
make it through the season
unscathed there was a year brett favre
lost like 20 pounds and he got banged up
that year you got to have some thickness
to play quarterback in the nfl
or you're going to get thrown around
like a ragdoll
all right the julio jones situation at
least we know that he wants out
[Laughter]
well i i hey it's a great interview
technique to call someone up
when you're on the air and they don't
know that's the best way to get to the
truth now it may get you in prison
depending upon the laws of the
jurisdiction where you are when you do
it
but well done send the pulitzer to
shannon sharp
for pulling that off but you know
they've managed to keep this quiet for
months
but dan the falcons have been trying to
trade this guy
since really actively the monday before
the draft three different reporters all
at the same time
put a flag in the ground that the
falcons are willing to trade julio jones
that's the team putting it out there
here's the challenge they want a second
round pick
how much of his salary do they have to
pay when they trade him
to get that second round pick and what's
their priority
maximizing draft capital or clearing the
most cap space possible
the more cap space you clear the less
money you pay
out of that 15.3 million that's the less
you're gonna get in return form and they
got to figure out
where their sweet spot is and and i've
yet to hear of anybody who's seriously
interested in him i think they're
waiting for the falcons to get more
realistic in their expectations
and what they want a first rounder
you're saying maybe second at best
they want a second round or they're
saying they want a first rounder because
they want a second rounder
and again you get a second rounder but
you got to pay seven million
of the 15.3 million dollars that's the
thing how much how much of that
cap space do they want to eat
to get the second round pick remember
and i'm not saying it will come to this
but there's a cash value
for draft picks the texans gave the
browns
a second round pick to take bro
osweiler's
16 million guaranteed off the books four
years ago
and we've seen this with the panthers
when they traded teddy bridgewater to
the broncos
they got a sixth round pick and they
paid seven of 10 million dollars
to get it how much of the 15.3 will the
falcons have to pay that's really the
question
that i think the falcons would just
assume not try to answer
yeah i'm trying to figure out could the
packers
bring in julio jones hey dan i said this
last friday on pft live
if you want to mend fences with aaron
rodgers you go to him and you say here's
what we're going to do
we're going to restructure your contract
we're going to create some cap space
we're going to have a structure to your
deal that forces us to keep you for the
next three years
jordan loves irrelevant don't worry
about him anymore even though he said
he's not worried about him
it's what he represents that he's
worried about not an issue you're not
going to get
thrown overboard we're tied to you and
with the extra cap space
oh and by the way we're going to
restructure devante adams we free up
this money we're going to go get julio
jones we're going all in
13-3 each of the last two years nfc
championship each of the last two years
julio jones puts us over the top let's
do this
let's mend fences let's rebuild the
bridge that would be an easy thing to do
but there's no indication that packers
are even thinking about doing it dan
i don't know if this is in your field of
expertise being a lawyer but what
happened on fox sports one
where you record somebody in the state
of california
that's against the law oh it's two-party
state two-party consent some states are
one party some states are two-party oh
dan i'm i'm well aware
i'm well aware of that and and uh i
don't know if you guys have tried to get
the clip
from fs1 but apparently they're not
giving out the clip so
i suspect there's an appreciation within
the building
that maybe something happened that
shouldn't have happened all you got to
do right out of the gates is say we're
on the air but if you do that you may
you may not get the answer that you want
to the question that you ask by the way
have you ordered your tebow jersey
i i have i've ordered five of them okay
one
for uh every member of the family and
and
two for me so you know if i gain a
little weight it'll still
it'll still fit or if i want to wear a
sweater under it or something it won't
be too tight see i think you're being uh
very sarcastic here no i'm serious i've
ordered a tebow jersey mike
85 and 15. although if you read the fine
print
when you order the jersey it won't be
shipped
until after his number becomes official
see it's not going to be 85.
once they dump gardner-minshew he's
going to be in number 15
that's when you get your jersey just in
time for them to cut him
what happened to gardner minshew well
look
i i was a big proponent after the 2019
season of keeping everything in place
coach gm quarterback let's give this
sixth round guy from washington state a
chance
to become whatever it is that we thought
he could be
and they won their first game they beat
the colts and then the wheels came off
after that so
i think they're waiting for a trade
offer for gardner minshew and as soon as
that happens they move on and
tim tebow's back in number 15 where he
belongs dan what if aaron rodgers lee
well the packers won a quarterback in
return
i well that's not that's not the
the best possible endorsement of jordan
love is it no if you want a quarterback
in return hey come on in and enjoy
jordan love
waiting to take your job oh my god
uh thank you mike great to talk to you
all right that's uh mike florian